when kofi 19 first made its way
internationally the world was in
shambles people were panning buying and
resources began to decrease
significantly this can also be said for
disposable face masks as at that point
in time the number of surgical face
masks had declined worldwide so much so
that countries were rapidly mass
producing face masks prioritizing
deployment towards the health and
service sectors
this also meant that the quality of the
face mask went down to the point where
they started to make do with fabric or
cloth masks with that being said could
this revolutionize the way we actually
wear masks currently and in the future
behold the lg pericare face mask it's
basically an air purifier that you can
wear on your face ever since miss rona
coronavirus has made its way to well
everywhere masks like these have been
made mandatory to
curb the spread of corvette 19. aren't
you just tired of running out of face
masks and then you have to get to the
store or perhaps if you wear cloth masks
yourselves
it's probably in the washing machine
right now and what if you ever had an
emergency and you know you gotta you
gotta wait until it dries right not to
mention they're wearing face masks for a
prolonged period of time especially the
ones that are made out of cloth fabric
could ruin your handsome or beautiful
complexion what we call
mask knee what's it called max knee
abrasions or even fungal infections on
your skin
when you wear masks for way too long now
let's look at the cons here right fabric
mask hot and stuffy
not really have that much of
breathability in it and if you buy the
standard surgical mask that cost what
fifty dollars a box here in singapore
you might end up getting a box that
actually has cheap materials and very
low quality ones as well ear straps will
just simply snap off and and anyone
these days can actually fake a
certification so you never know what
you're gonna get not to mention glasses
man glasses they tend to fog a lot when
you wear a face mask so with all those
problems lg has come to a point where
they decided to make their own face mask
this is the lg prerecare wearable face
mask it's essentially an air purifier
for your face
now you have some fancy technology
inside this mask more on that later the
mask aims to make your life safer as
well as more convenient by just having
literally a single mask that you can
wear for a very very long time and
priced at a very hefty and surprising
cost of 229 singapore dollars you got to
put this to the test now if you're
wondering what this is all about this is
not just any other case for your mouse
but this is the lg pre-care wearable air
purifier case
now what's great about it is that you
can fit your mask when you're not using
it but as soon as you close it
what it does is that it actually blasts
uv rays to kill any remaining bacteria
as well as a drying mode so you can make
sure that all your photos are dry and
doesn't collect bacteria
inside the mask
so first let's take a look at the design
the mask itself appears to be a lot
bigger than most face masks on the
market because of this
and it does tend to draw some
unnecessary attention to yourself but if
you like the added attention that it
brings then perhaps this mask is
definitely for you as you can see the
mask does come in only white which can
be a little bit difficult to keep clean
after a long time
or you know if you don't wash your hands
like some people
like the air purifiers the lg purika
wearable mask
does have two h13 heat pop filters and
these filters help to block out unwanted
foreign materials and airborne particles
and if you don't know how good these
photos are these filters are so fine
that is small enough to block out 99
of airborne viruses and bacteria all
while maintaining proper ventilation for
the wearer the mouse is also equipped
with two fans
that allows for better ventilation and
breathability so to turn on the mask all
you need to do is just press the little
bitty button over here
once you hit a beep the fans actually
start spinning there's three different
fan speeds the first one is pairs when
you're idling or working on your desk
the second one is followed by two beeps
and you use this mode when you're
walking around and with the third mode
you get three beeps the manual says that
it's meant for brisk walking
but we've tried this with running
jogging and working out at the gym as
well so i guess you could say that this
three different modes varies in the
intensity of how much breathing you need
while wearing this face mask with that
being said of course you need power to
run this face mask of course this is no
issue as it comes with its very own
built-in
820 milliamp hour battery powered by a
usbc cable that comes with the box all
you need to do is just hook it up to a
portable charger a usb hub and pretty
much anything else that helps you charge
the mask now moving on to the lg precare
wearable air purifier case it is able to
sanitize your face mask in just half an
hour and of course it does have a drying
mode
so it helps dry out any moisture in
approximately four hours or at least
until the indicator lights turn off and
that's where the beauty comes in because
it can charge the mask at the same time
in just two hours now the mask itself
can be worn pretty much just like any
other face mask and the inner face guard
this silicone thingy right here supports
this by ensuring there's a seal between
the mask and the wearer now the face
guard is made out of silicone so it's
soft to the touch so it's suitable for
all the everyday use and because it's
made out of silicone cleaning it it's no
harder than giving it a few wet wipes
and you're done
and when you're done for the day and
safe at home and all you need to do is
to take this magnetic usbc charging head
from the case attach it to the mask set
your face mask down to the case close it
turn it on once for uv sanitation mode
and one more time
to start the drying process as well it's
as easy as that now with that said you
can expect the mask to have some wear
and tear over time you do need to change
the heap of filters every month or so
and the inner cover do need to get
replaced once it starts getting dirty
you know it when you smell it
but lg has solved this problem by
actually selling the individual
components or spare parts which you can
find on the lg online store of course
the inner cover comes in a pack of 10
right out of the box so it will take
some time before you need another
replacement so from the heap of filters
to the inner covers even the neckband
and the earband can be replaced now you
can get a set of some of the items we're
going to list it right here
some of the items include the hipaa
filters the inner cover
the
ear straps as well as the fancy neckband
we'll talk about that in a bit
is this long enough
should be
now the mouse also comes with a neckband
for better support via extension and the
neck band can be attached to the face
mask by attaching to the ear straps the
neck band then extends over to the back
of the wearer's head and onto the other
side of the ear strap now this is ideal
for situations where your ears are
covered perhaps you're wearing
headphones and it's best for frontline
workers who actually have to work around
the clock for prolonged periods of time
it's also ideal for situations where you
actually have an air rash when you wear
a mask for long periods of time this is
also suitable for wearers whose ears are
inaccessible due to clothing such as
knick-ups and hijabs
what's up muslim sisters
and that pretty much covers the face
mask in general so let's move on to the
case now if you have any other lg thank
you devices lying around house such as
your fridge or tv then perhaps you might
want to keep tabs on the case itself now
the great thing about the thank you app
is that once it's paired with the case
it does give you some bits of
information such as how long it takes to
dry the mask the battery life of the
mask as well as the time it takes to
completely disinfect the mask so it's a
pretty neat feature from lg that rolled
out with the case and the mask so you
can just keep track of things now i've
used this mask for quite some time both
indoors and outdoors and i have to say
that it actually works pretty well and
just like any other regular mask is
trying to get people to understand you
because of its sheer size and nature of
the mask it is inevitable that it will
block out speech so this means you have
to talk louder and clearer or you end up
sounding like bane for the dark knight
rises
a man i was murdered
by it can you hear me now
anybody
and for wearers who wear eyeglasses like
myself this is like the gift from the
heavens this mask is a one-stop solution
for prevention of foggy glasses now
we're not going to go too in depth about
how this works but essentially the
airflow goes from the filter into our
lungs we exhume the air and it gets
redirected downwards through an exhaust
pot below the mask as well as through
the inner covers
and because there's a nice seal from the
silicone interface guard you don't get
the air going upwards into your glasses
yes science now if you want to stay
active and go out for a run or hit the
gym but still prefer to stay on the
safer side you can use this during your
workouts you do have to adjust the ear
straps so it fits just right without the
mask bobbing up and down with that said
because of his two fans and using it on
the third mode makes this very good for
breathability in fact i still prefer the
lg purican mask over a fabric one you
know like how you
wear a face mask and you just
throw that condensation and just makes
it even like harder or like feels
heavier to just
breathe yeah that's you don't you don't
get this with this mask as the saying
goes what you pay is what you get it's
one of the better looking face masks and
perhaps a safer option than the general
cloth and fabric face mask that we all
know today now with all of these cool
features it does come at a premium price
the mars retails for 229 singapore
dollars and the case comes at 199
singapore dollars
both of them are sold separately but we
do highly recommend that you get both as
the case not only helps disinfect the
wearable air purifier but it also helps
prolong the shelf life of the wearable
air purifier with that this brings both
devices to a total of 348 singapore
dollars and though it might sway some
buyers the benefits that can be reaped
is totally worth it it's literally like
as if you're wearing an air purifier on
your face
this mask is perfect for those who have
allergies and all sensitive to particles
in the air it's also great for those who
like to take the technological step in
improving their mask wearing experience
this is one option that you should
strongly consider if you have spare
change
[Music]
you